foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar single
molecule proteomics using protein
identification by short epitope mapping
I am antonina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by elaborates and brought to
you by Nautilus biotechnology
to learn more please visit nautilus.bio
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
parag Malik founder and chief scientist
at Nautilus biotechnology
Dr Malik you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone thanks so much for joining
us today
I'm really excited to share with you
some of the foundations of nautilus's
platform
we shared some of this new data at hupo
very recently and I'm excited to share
with with you today
just to set the foundation
it's important to think about the
landscape of proteomics
we understand that proteins are the key
drivers of biology and there are a
number of challenges in the field
looking at protein protein interactions
discovering better biomarkers digging
into mechanisms of signaling and and
ultimately finding the next set of drug
targets despite this tremendous
importance of the field
when we look out at the landscape of
proteomics we recognize that there is a
massive Gulf between
progress that is made the influence and
penetrance of genomics versus proteomics
and we can see this just in the
publication landscape between the two
over the past 20 years
this is despite our ongoing knowledge
and increasing awareness that the genome
and transcriptome and proteome aren't
particularly well correlated shown in
the center here is one of the earliest
proteogenomic papers from wehood and
Rudy abresolved looking at yeast and
I don't know if you all can see the
amazingly strong correlation between the
transcriptome and protium this was then
replicated more recently in work by
being Zhang's group and the cptac again
looking across hundreds of tumor
specimens and really finding no
significant correlation between the
transcriptome and the proteome and this
makes sense biologically
you have an entirely novel length scale
and an entirely novel regulatory scale
it would be terrifically wasteful for
the cell to have the transcriptome in
the podium perfectly correlated
additionally we have tremendous
variation in both transcription rates
transcript degradation rates translation
rates and protein degradation rates that
would make it incredibly improbable for
the transom and the proteome to be
perfectly correlated
as a preamble it's just important to
recognize that the different regulatory
scales cooperate to drive biology
now one of the challenges that proteomex
has faced is that it is incredibly hard
to measure the proteome
the main reasons are really four-fold
first off proteins Span in incredibly
wide dynamic range
within cells you have proteins like
transcription factors that may be
present in a handful of copies per cell
as well as cytoskeletal proteins and
ribosomal proteins that may be present
in in millions of copies per
person additionally there's no PCR for
proteins
unlike the genome where we can take
advantage of polymerases to copy the
genome and transcriptome that isn't
possible for proteins if you only have
one molecule of a protein it's all you
have you need a technique that is
sensitive enough to measure a single
molecule
among the other principal challenges is
that proteins themselves are
biophysically extremely diverse unlike
the genome and transcriptome that are
are biophysically very similar to each
other the every single protein is its
own unique snowflake with a range of
charges and hydrophobicities and sizes
and making interrogation very difficult
and then compounding that proteins
themselves are modified with a series of
glycosylations and phosphorylations
methylations generating proteoforms such
that each individual molecule may have a
diversity of protein forms it inhabits
if we look at the landscape today and we
ask the question what are we able to
look at with existing Technologies
though incredibly powerful there remain
a huge set of proteins that are not
routinely queryable within a standard
assay
and then if one shifts the landscape to
look at proteoforms we really don't have
tools available to dive deeply into the
protein landscape
despite how incredibly powerful today's
tools are it's natural to take a step
back and say all right well
what if we were starting over if we were
to start over from scratch
what would we want our proteomics
platform to be able to do
and so we can write down a list of key
criteria and I'm always curious to hear
what are what are all of your key
criteria in developing an entirely novel
platform
when Nautilus sat down these were the
criteria we came up with
first we wanted a platform that was
comprehensive something that could
measure substantively all of the
proteins in a sample
it of course needs to be sensitive
measuring those very rare molecules
but at the same time needing to have a y
dynamic range as we commented on earlier
the scale of the proteome is fast and so
we need a technique that is able to
measure across that entire range
any scientific analytic technique of
course needs to be reproducible and
robust that gives the path towards
Clinic
um ultimately we have a very large
number of samples particularly as we
start thinking about temporal studies
and large cohort studies and so a rapid
run time is critical
and then I'll just mention quickly if we
want a platform that's really easy to
use something that is accessible to any
lab any biologist
so that the proteome is available to
everybody
taking these criteria Nautilus
decided to move in the direction of a
single molecule intact protein
measurement platform
and there are a couple of reasons that
this is valuable
first a single molecule counter is
definitionally the most sensitive you
can be measuring individual molecules
but also at the single molecule level
the challenge of protein quantification
fundamentally changes
if I can identify each individual
molecule I get my quantification
free
by simply counting up all of those
identifications so with the single
molecule level identification becomes
quantification
one of the major reasons why we focused
on looking at intact proteins on the
Nautilus platform
is because of the potential for an
increased dynamic range at a comparable
throughput
digesting each protein into potentially
hundreds of tryptic peptides requires a
larger number of measurements in order
to cover a similar dynamic range
Additionally the data interpretation in
the protein assembly problem is
complicated
lastly by not digesting the proteins it
becomes possible to measure proteoforms
to say oh this particular molecule has
three phosphorylations at these
different positions some information
that's lost when you digest the protein
now
there are some substantial challenges in
building a single molecule-based protein
analysis platform
first how do you guarantee that you're
actually looking at single molecules
second one needs to have a technique but
it's actually sensitive enough to
measure each individual molecule and
then lastly it needs to not only be a
sensitive technique it also needs to be
incredibly fast so that you can measure
a large number of molecules to achieve
the dynamic range necessary to profile
the entirety of the proteome
the Nautilus approach really has two key
foundational tenets the first is a
sample preparation method that enables
single molecule intact protein
deposition onto a nanopattern array the
second is an iterative affinity region
binding platform that feeds machine
learning
digging into that that platform a little
bit more it's Reliant upon three sub
pieces first a set of proprietary
multi-affinity probes
um special Affinity reagent reagents
um an instrument that is able to
iteratively interrogate the same sample
immobilized on the ship over and over
and over again and a machine learning
piece that is able to take that
information and convert it into protein
identities and quantities and
proteoforms
we're going to walk through each of the
different pieces of the platform in the
coming few minutes
starting off with sample preparation in
single molecule deposition
the way that many people address this
challenge of single molecule protein
deposition is with a technique known as
limiting dilution
where they take their sample and spread
it out at very low concentration over a
very large surface
this approach those though effective
leads to the vast majority of your space
being empty 90 plus of a chip area being
empty additionally this loading is
what's known as poisson loading which
means that 50 of the optically
resolvable areas contain multiple
molecules
um so 25 contain two 12 percent contain
three and on and on and on
so it's challenging to guarantee
individual molecules additionally for
efficiency you're wasting a lot of
Imaging time with empty space
this point of measuring a very large
number of molecules is critical that
scale is important in capturing the
proteome to look at this one can take a
snapshot of the distribution of protein
abundances within a cell as shown here
on the left
and this is taken from existing
estimates of protium abundance
distributions and deposit in those and
simulate the deposition of those
proteins onto a chip and ask how well or
is one able to cover the entirety of
this distribution as a function of the
number of molecules that you measure and
what you're looking at here on the right
is exactly that so each one of these
bars represents the protein deposition
as a function of the number of landing
pads available
the width of each bar corresponds to at
a given concentration amount how much of
that uh how much of how many of the
proteins at that concentration band were
able to be successfully deposited and
one can see that as one approaches uh 10
to the 8 10 to the 9 10 of the 10
landing pads per chip one is able to
cover substantively all of the podium
across an incredibly wide dynamic range
for cell materials this a chip with
approximately 10 billion landing pads is
able to cover over nine orders of
magnitude and dynamic range in in blood
this ends up being about 11 and a half
orders of magnitude so measuring a large
number of molecules is critical
and
is the major reason for art significant
investment in a single molecule protein
deposition approach
moving beyond limiting dilution
now the way that most people have
attempted to uh to bridge super poisson
deposition is through creating landing
pads that are really small
um so that you have stair hindrance
between molecules and no molecules can
land on the same location
the team at Nautilus came up with a
really clever approach it's often very
challenging to fabricate
chips that have very small feature sizes
so instead of making landing pads that
are very small the team model is instead
decided to make the proteins big and the
way that they do this is through using
an intermediate scaffold molecule which
is shown here
the scaffold made out of DNA is quite
large on the order of hundreds of
nanometers but
this nanoparticle is very unique unlike
traditional nanoparticles of this size
that may have hundreds of thousands of
conjugation sites this particular
nanoparticle has exactly one and what's
shown here is the general workflow where
we would start with our nanoparticle
scaffolds shown here in an AFM image
conjugate them to a protein and each
scaffold can hold exactly one protein we
then deposit these scaffolds onto our
nanofabricated array and each Landing
Pad can hold exactly one scaffold so
because we have one scaffold per Landing
Pad one protein per scaffold mixing them
together Auto assembles a hyper dense
single molecule protein array
just to show in a little bit more in
detail what the sample prep workflow
looks like it's again our goal was to
make it as simple as possible it broadly
looks like a traditional Mass
spectrometry based proteomics workflow
where we start with a sample of Interest
extract the proteins from from it label
them with a click reagent in this case
an NHS methyl tetrazine
we then mix those with the nanoparticle
scaffold that has the tricyclooctane the
other half of the click region which
creates scaffold protein conjugates and
then deposit them on the chip
to validate that we were in fact
generating a single molecule approaching
array one can do an experiment where one
admixes different colors of
scaffold protein conjugates together and
deposits them on the chip
and zooming in what you're looking at
now is a chip in which we've deposited
two different colors of scaffolds
and what you can see uh is that there
are very few instances where there are
multiple colors at the same site
so if you had one just one that was
green it would be a green you have just
one that was purple it would be purple
if you had a green and a purple
co-localized it would be white and so in
general you can see uh an occasional
white predominantly a field of purple
and green uh in a control
um
um using slightly different scaffolds
you end up with a field of white and so
in general we anticipate extremely high
occupancy of these chips and extremely
low co-localization
for additional detail we recommend
checking out our
our preprint in BIO archive
just to show a little bit more detail in
general the reactions are completed very
quickly within a matter of hours and
then the chips themselves are able to
contain billions of landing pads per
chip what you're looking at here is a
very small section of a chip each chip
contains approximately 10 000 of these
sections each one of as we zoom in you
can see each of the individual protein
molecules on the Chip And so this area
alone contains over a hundred thousand
uh protein molecules and as I mentioned
before you'll notice that it is it is
highly complete and so in general we
anticipate occupancies in the high 90
percent
hopefully you now have a better
understanding of how single molecule
deposition aspect of the platform works
and will transition to diving into the
second aspect of the platform which is
the iterative measurement
under the the at the heart of the
platform inside the instrument is a
integrated fluidics an Imaging system
wherein each
and each iteration probes are incubated
allowed to be rinsed and then imaged we
then wash them off and that consists of
one cycle the Imaging is done with
fluorescence we use
fluorescently labeled affinity reagents
for this and in each cycle you will
incubate rinse
image wash and do this over and over and
over again and because each molecule is
fully immobilized it can be repeatedly
interrogated building up increasingly
more information about each molecule
cycle after cycle after cycle
one of the really unique aspects of the
platform is that even though it is a
single molecule measurement platform it
is not a single fluorophore measurement
platform and that's important because
that is a key part of how we're able to
image as quickly as we are to again
measure a large number of molecules
in fact we attach our Affinity reagents
to another special type of nanoparticle
which contains both multiple Affinity
reagents probes as well as as many many
fluorophores so these nanoparticles are
very bright allowing for a rapid
Imaging time
and these nanoparticle labels are
compatible with either off-the-shelf
targeted antibodies or the novel
multi-affinity probes that we've been
building that Target short amino acid
sequences
to test that the proteins remained
probable and stayed attached to the chip
we can do multi-cycle experiments this
is showing one we'll show another one
later in the presentation showing that
we have very negligible protein loss the
protein State very well attached to the
chip
so that's like really the core of the
platform but one of the key questions we
need to answer is how do we identify
individual molecules how do we determine
which molecule is which they're
scattered randomly throughout the array
and that's really this this the second
part
um that relies Upon Our proprietary
multi-affinity probes and our machine
learning to identify each individual
molecule in a Technique we call prism to
learn more I recommend checking out the
the bio archive preprint
the heart of the platform relies upon a
special series of affinity reagents that
instead of targeting whole proteins
Target very short epitopes within those
proteins typically three to four amino
acids long
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to probe iteratively
with each of these molecules building up
a profile that any individual molecule
that says that you bound to probe one
two six Etc and then take that
information and ask what protein is
compatible with that pattern of binding
we then determine on a per molecule
basis which protein is present and then
derive our quantification by counting up
all of those identifications
in a way this approach is is most
analogous to a massively parallel
machine learning version of the game
Guess Who
one at one particular location on the
array one way one could figure out the
identity is by using
tens of thousands of specific Affinity
reagent probes essentially asking the
question are you Maria are you Robert
are you Charles are you George but that
would be that would require tens of
thousands of perfect Affinity reagents
it would also be extremely time
consuming
so and guess who what we do instead is
we ask much less specific questions we
ask are you wearing a hat are you bald
are you wearing a mustache and while
these questions themselves are much more
General and much less specific one can
arrive at the right answer
shockingly efficiently through asking a
series of
less specific questions
um to dig into this in a little more
detail one can look at again one
particular molecule perhaps egfr and
observe a binding pattern of a series of
short epitopes
one then takes that information and as I
mentioned before looks across the
proteome to say what protein could be
compatible with this pattern of epitose
and derive a probabilistic
interpretation thereof so as you can see
below for a series of different proteins
if we ask the question what protein is
compatible with this series of bindings
even though each Probe on its own is not
particularly protein specific the
combination of all of them together is
shockingly specific differentiating
across many proteins
um we can observe this in a simulation
shown here where we're looking at one
protein and looking at many many touches
probes landing on that protein and you
can see early on it is unclear what this
protein is there are many possibilities
but once we get to about 10 or 15
touches it becomes vanishingly
improbable the protein is anything other
than
the correct answer
one of the unique aspects of a single
molecule binding platform is that each
individual molecule may be probed uh
there is stochasticity there are probes
that that could theoretically bind that
won't but prism is incredibly tolerant
to this diversity of probe bindings and
that's one of the really unique and
special aspects and why this is in part
a machine learning problem is to take
into account all of the stochasticity
the true true positive binding the false
negative binding false positive binding
in order to infer the identity of each
protein molecule at each location
one of the common questions is how many
cycles how many probings are required in
order to deconvolve substantially all of
the podium recall that if we were to do
this with specific Affinity reagents
this would typically be on the order of
tens of thousands of reagents but by
using our proprietary multi-affinity
probes we instead are potentially able
to deconval substantively all of the
chronium in a small number of hundreds
of Cycles somewhere between two and
three hundred Cycles
once it's protein has been identified as
I mentioned uh we look at the entire
workflow we start with our collection of
our Imaging data our multi-cycle Imaging
data
take that boil it down to a coordinate
binding Matrix which essentially says at
this given coordinate we had this
pattern of binding we had binding from
probes 2 and 3 and 85 and 92
we then infer on a per molecule basis
which protein was present and then roll
that up together um by counting up all
of those identifications to get our
quantification
hopefully this has given you a bit of a
foundation to understand the the
underpinnings of the method
one of the questions that often arises
is well how does one build these
proprietary multi-affinity probes or
more skeptically can these things
actually exist we have a number of
different approaches that we've taken
this is one of them really Reliant upon
phage display we start with a large
Library pan for antibodies that
recognize short epitopes select and
build antibodies
um
um from those selections and then shown
here on the right are a few examples of
affinity reagents that we've built
um really looking at their ec50s and so
uh both testing for On Target binding
and off-target binding and what you can
see for instance here is a probe
recognizing The Motif ywl the ywl
has incredibly strong binding
low tens of picomolar binding to its
intended target and negligible binding
to an off Target
this is really the first step is
building a set of incredibly
efficient short epitope multi-affinity
probes the second step is characterizing
and validating that not only do they
bind to their target of interest but
what else do they bind to we know that
all Affinity reagents have have some
cross reactivity so one of our next key
steps is to actually examine that and so
we do a lot of work in characterizing
these probes looking across peptide
arrays doing extensive epitope mapping
and one of our often conclusions is that
any given probe will bind to a
neighborhood typically of biosimilars
around uh it's selected Target
one of the other common questions is is
there a special magical perfect set of
targets that this works for uh and works
better for or can it be nearly any
arbitrary collection of of two to three
hundred epitope targets
and in looking at that question what you
can see is if we look at the most
optimal set of targets
um it is able to efficiently cover the
vast majority of the proteome in
approximately two to three hundred
probes and Cycles if we look Instead at
a random collection of probes and
targets
while they don't perform quite as well
the Delta is relatively small
particularly as one gets out to larger
numbers of Cycles so really um the prism
method is incredibly tolerant to false
positives and false negatives it is not
Reliant upon a singular perfect set of
affinity reagents
um and is is able to to account for a
lot of experimental noise
to put prism into practice
one of the really exciting New pieces of
data that I have to share with you today
is is from a larger experiment where
reformed up to 70 cycles of Imaging
across dozens of multi Affinity probes
including some negative controls we
deposited a series of proteins um
protein scaffold conjugates onto work
chips
um and then incubated
imaged removed over and over and over
and over again and as shown previously
the proteins are retained extremely well
throughout the entire experiment
and then one of the key questions is
what does decoding look like in practice
and so this is an example of one
particular molecule really digging in
and asking the question all right what
is our confidence in this particular
protein versus any other protein in the
database
and what you can see here is with
between model protein 1 and model
protein two uh and in the middle is when
we have an observed binding event
so
um potentially we had a series of
different Target epitopes um some of
which are shown here and you can see for
instance a binding here which is giving
us some additional confidence that this
particular molecule is model protein one
this epitope not being present in model
protein 2.
um continuing along we have another
series of of touches on this protein
binding events that again boost our
confidence in this being model protein 1
instead of model protein 2. you'll
notice that this particular binding
event this epitope was present in both
monoprotein 1 and model protein 2. so we
don't get any decoding or probabilistic
boost from that binding event in terms
of differentiating these particulars of
proteins
as we continue along we get increasing
binding events to this Target and
ultimately end up more than 10 000 times
it is more than ten thousand times more
likely that the protein present at this
location is model protein one versus
model protein two
um
and we look at this across an entire
database of different proteins
I'm looking across a sample we also do a
number of of computational analyzes to
look at false Discovery rate to set
different false Discovery grade
thresholds these involve shuffling of
the database shuffling of the probe
binding as well as doing leave one out
analyzes Etc on binding and one can see
across a particular sample incredibly
High counts for model protein 1 and very
low false Discovery rates very low
counts for any other other protein
so the shuffling of the data the FDR
estimation really helps us validate the
identifications are not an artifact of
random binding
oh
uh We've focused on so far today has
really been nautilus's approach for
broad cell decoding I'm really looking
to measure uh the width and breadth of
the podium
the platform can also be used in a
targeted manner to examine proteoforms
um in this in when used in this manner
the fundamentals of the platform remain
the same we're still immobilizing
individual protein molecules on the
platform we're still probing them
iteratively with a series of affinity
reagents
but instead of using our our
multi-finity probes targeting short
epitopes we now can use probes targeting
individual post-translational
modification sites or specific targeted
proteins and this allows us to build up
a profile of each individual molecule
again at a level of detail
that allows one to look at proteoforms
proteoforms of course are critical
drivers of phenotype we recognize that
after uh after
coming from the genome going through
alternative splicing into the trans in
the transcriptome we already end up with
a wide variety of protein isoforms each
one of these isoforms can then be
modified with a series of possible
post-translational modifications
methylations phosphorylations Etc that
lead to a potentially millions of
different proteoforms
an intact protein
approach is necessary because of samples
like this one so consider for a moment
if you had a sample like this where you
had one molecule that was triply
phosphorylated at different sites and
then two molecules that were unmodified
this sample would look identical when
digested to the sample on the right
where we had three molecules Each of
which were modified at a different loci
even though biologically biochemically
these are very different samples that
might behave very differently and have
radically different uh
cellular impact
or targeted protein analysis as I
mentioned before we start by
immobilizing our proteins we'll then
probe with a targeted probe such as for
egfr shown in this instance to localize
where all the egfrs are and then come in
with a position specific probe that
allows us to say oh you have a
modification at this loci
wipe it off come in again with another
probe that binds to a different loci and
again build up a pattern that says oh
this particular molecule has
modifications at those sites
do this again wipe off
and over time again building up more and
more and more information on a per
molecule basis and with uh with as few
as six Cycles one is able to potentially
elaborate 32 distinct protein forms
one study that we've been excited to
work with our partners at genentechon
has been looking at the protein Tau
which is of course a critical protein
involved in neurodegenerative diseases
um Tau has a number of different
phosphorylations it also has a variety
of different isoforms and so in this
experiment we first immobilize our
proteins to determine where the Tau
molecules are probe with different
phosphoryl antiphosphorylation sites
motifs to build up again on a molecule
by molecule basis information about what
isoform is present at a given location
and what possible modifications are
present and in one experiment to
validate the approach we took a series
of samples of different different
isoforms and protein formation
proteoforms put them into the platform
and asked all right are we able to
determine first the right protein form
within that sample next we mix them
together to ask can we quantitatively
determine how much of each proteoform is
present in a complex mixture containing
an admixture of different purview forms
something that we believe is incredibly
challenging to do with any other method
and really it's the unique capability of
the platform to iteratively probe each
molecule over and over and over again in
as an intact protein that allows us to
dig into the molecular heterogeneity at
this level of detail
studying protein forms
just to sum up the Nautilus proteum
analysis platform is really has really
been designed to deliver sensitivity at
scale
platform coming back to our key
aspirational goals within building the
platform has been designed to be
extremely comprehensive ultimately
measuring substantively all of the
proteome it is a quantitative digital
readout the sample preparation being
relatively straightforward and the uh
the iterative probing being very robust
um aiming towards an incredibly
reproducible method
we've talked about as a single molecule
counter it is definitionally incredibly
sensitive potentially able to measure
low abundance proteins
the platform has been designed to be
incredibly High throughput measuring
billions of molecules within about a day
and again
one of our key criteria was was ease of
use wanting something that was simple
that
was accessible to the broader biological
community
I'll just close by mentioning that we
recently launched the single molecule
proteomics first access challenge it's a
really exciting opportunity deadline in
mid-February please do submit your
applications winners of the application
will analyze 12 of your samples using
the novel as proteomics analysis
platform provide you with a summary
report and also support travel expenses
to percent uh present your work so I'll
stop there thank you all very much again
for your attention today
I'm looking forward to taking questions
thank you Dr Malik for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for now let's
get started
our first question
um has a few questions within it says
great presentation thank you for sharing
this wonderful study my care my cure
queries sorry are is it only
quantitative tests
um says only proteins are present or no
can this technology be used for
quantitative analytical assay such as
preparing calibration measuring proteins
quantitatively if quantitative do you
know the sensitivity of this technology
super that's a that's a great question
the
that the assay is absolutely
quantitative
um they're really what's really special
about it being a single molecule-based
technique is that while on a per
molecule basis you are making an
identification you're making a detection
but then quantitation comes from summing
up all of those identifications
literally counting so if I make a
hundred counts of of given protein I sum
that up and I say I had a hundred
molecules present on the Chip
And so I it absolutely can be used
quantitatively one can potentially think
about
adding additional calibration standards
as well on top of that but
definitionally as a single molecule
counter it is quantitative and from a
sensitivity perspective that there is no
transform to brightness or intensity uh
it and so
um
theoretically practically
um you uh a single molecule counter is
definitionally the most sensitive kind
of measurement that one can make now
that does need to be caveated with
factors like non-specific binding and
false positive rates and low detection
events um so the the
absolute limit of quantitation while
theoretically single a single molecule
amongst a field of billions
um is uh is is something that we're
still working through to to provide a
really detailed
um uh titration series data for for
everyone
um
great thank you for that
um another question here what are the
factors to consider for false
identification and quantitation
so that's a that's a really important
question and something we think about a
lot when we think about
um so I'll I'll really focus on the
false identification part because that
rolls up directly into quantitation as I
mentioned before so when we think about
false identification the way we think
about it is very similarly to mass
spectrometry based proteomics techniques
what's the likelihood that a given
identification would be incorrect and
what are the factors that derive that
one some false positive rate associated
with binding events that are not
um that are that are spurious
um so you have the likelihood of false
positive binding events you have given a
set of binding events what how close is
the next most probable protein now in
general
um as you start to get a larger number
of binding events the next closest
protein tends to be quite far away but
one can ask the question
if I had one less binding event or two
less binding events
um am I still confident that it is this
particular protein
um you can also Shuffle Around The
Binding events and and examine how that
might change what your potential protein
is and so in the same way that we can do
Target decoy in Mass spectrometry we
also can do a similar Target decoy
approach with this method so we actually
calculate multiple
false Discovery rates to account for
variation in protein database variation
in binding events variation in uh in
false positive binding rates Etc to
build our confidence in any given
identification and to provide references
for false identification rates
um and then that directly translates to
quantitation because as as your false
identification rate
um is loosened there will be some impact
on your quantitation because your counts
are going to change subtly
thank you
our next question
um what are the databases used for
protein reference and determination and
is this a species agnostic method
yeah so um so the method is sequence is
species agnostic because the probes that
we use Target very short epitopes three
to four amino acids long
um the the species of origin of the
sample doesn't matter these are not
organism specific probes in any way
consequently the database that we use
for human studies is typically a uniprot
database but
um any any reference proteome database
can be used so for instance if when
we're studying plants one could use a
plant reference uh
um if one we're studying studying
translational systems mice Etc yeast all
of those are quite quite possible
great thank you we have some great
questions coming in another question are
there limitations to the sample types
that could be used with the platform
a great question
um and initially with the platform
we are focusing on on human cell lysates
as our as our initial uh initial foray
expanding from there into serum and
plasma
there are a couple particular types of
samples that may be more challenging
um so uh
for instance ffpe tissues where the
proteins are extremely cross-linked
we don't as yet we haven't as yet worked
through what might be required to get
from croplink proteins to single protein
molecules a few other sample types that
may potentially be challenging are
are our sample types composed
exclusively of very short peptides such
as the immunopeptidome and a third
sample type that may be challenging are
things like the metapodium going back to
our prior question when studying the
metapodium we don't have a good
reference protein database to to compare
to but outside of that we feel like it
is a broadly applicable approach
okay thank you
um another question how long does it
take to analyze the data
um so that's a that's a
when we think about data analysis there
are multiple phases of data analysis
there's the the very first uh phase
where you're just taking the image data
and and turning it into uh coordinate by
new matrices and then getting from there
to identifications and that that
effective time is on par with
experimental time
um the next phase I would say is
actually where the vast majority of the
data analysis time is spent which is
understanding the biology and I don't
have a great answer for you there
because it really depends on the
questions being asked and um
uh as with any High throughput data
modality
um those those analyzes can be quite
complex we're we're working actively to
try and simplify that as well for our
customers
um but that there's a lot of fun to be
had in diving into the quantitative
aspects of the data and how
um it connects to other data that you
may have as well
thank you we have time for just a few
more
um our next question here is how do you
remove the high Affinity antibodies
after each cycle
yeah that's a that's a great question uh
oftentimes when we think about the assay
like how do we we we're working really
hard to build Affinity reagents that are
very tight binders but how do we get rid
of them
um the
fortunately our proteins are immobilized
uh glued down to the surface and so
because they're glued down you can be
extremely harsh in your removal buffers
we often use things like 10 SDS as a
very as a removal that is non-protein
damaging it's not chemically active it's
not going to
break bonds or damage the proteins but
it'll do a really good job of a lot of
of allowing the antibodies to unbind and
get washed away
thank you and we will end with this one
what are the major applications of the
platform
it's a really fun question and I would
flip it back to all of you I'm really
curious now that you understand a little
bit more about the platform what do you
want to do with it
um from uh from my perspective as a
member of the fields for many years
there there are a couple areas that I'm
really excited about but every time I
talk to somebody they often come and say
hey I'd love to do this I'd love to do
that
um so that's off the cuff I'd say the
the earliest applications are likely
um in both the therapeutic space and the
diagnostic space on the therapeutic
space uh finding uh novel targets
um proteins that are on the sole surface
of a disease tissue
um and not prevalent on
um on Associated healthy control tissues
um really that Target Discovery aspect
Downstream from that the mechanism of
action and toxicity studies
understanding with a lead compound
um if I treat a cell population what's
the network of coordinated consequences
there
um and then on the diagnostic side of
course finding those novel biomarkers
that differentiate either disease
populations from healthy populations or
responders from non-responders as well
as characterize drug activity
okay thank you Dr Malik um do you have
any final comments for our audience
hey I'll just thank you so much for for
joining us today I really appreciate you
taking the time and uh if you have other
follow-up questions please do just shoot
us a note we're really happy to chat
with you
thank you again Dr Malik for your time
today and your important research we'd
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor Nautilus for underwriting
today's educational webcast and before
we go I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions any questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with any one of
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye